the fourth generation ipad pro
the eighth generation ipad
and now the new fourth generation ipad
air powered by the a14 bionic chip this
processor is more powerful than the a12
found in the ipad and the a12z found in
the ipad pro
heck if you think about it this could be
the most affordable ipad pro yet
whoa whoa whoa wait a minute zacky that
can be right the ipad pro is simply the
best
all other ipads wish they were preps
that's
that's bad
okay we've got the best of the best but
not everybody uses every single feature
of the ipad pro to its full potential do
you really need quad speakers on the
ipad if you're using the airpods pro i
don't think so or having a one terabyte
ipad pro when you barely use the storage
so what the folks at apple have done is
to essentially well
strip
some small premium features
and
bing bam boom and got yourself this
the fourth generation ipad
this is good
what's up everybody zaki here from geek
culture and in this video we will be
taking an exclusive look at apple's
newest premium tablet of 2020 the fourth
generation ipad
stay
tuned
so why the different ipads
well it depends on what the right tablet
means to you the right size the right
prices the right amount of power the
right amount of functionality
and lastly the right part
so it has compatibility with the
accessories you want or already own
so without further ado let's get into
the nitty-gritty details
shall we
first of all the fourth generation ipad
looks stunning
ravishing
astonishing this is what what what i'm
gonna call it astonishing we will kindly
pass this geeky green unit with a
metallic finish that really matches our
gate culture colors
doesn't it just warm the cockles of your
heart
weighing in only 460 grams for the wi-fi
and cellular version it spots a similar
almost identical chassis as the
ipad pro and also features an h28 screen
with no home button
how about them apples
this model comes in an anti-reflective
coated 10.9 inch liquid retina display a
2360 by 1640 pixel resolution at
264 pixels per inch the fourth
generation ipad air has a 60hz refresh
rate and the screen brightness of 500
nits
of course the standout feature of the
fourth generation ipad is the a14 bionic
chip it's actually the first device of
any kind to be announced with this brand
new processor which is also powering the
iphone 12 smartphones this latest
generation a-series chip features a new
6-core design for 40 boost in cpu
performance and a new 4 core graphics
architecture for 30 improvement in well
graphics combining all that horsepower
with a 16 core newer engine
that delivers performances twice as fast
we are talking about like next level if
this was fast and furious
then we got like nascar
like
it's it's like f1 level f1 you know
we are talking about machine learning
apps editing working under heavy
workloads 3d rendering gaming wanna
trying to say it says blazing fast
we tested the fourth generation ipad air
and with a total score of six hundred
and fifty one thousand six hundred and
twenty seven points on
and
making the fourth generation ipad air
just shy of beating the third generation
ipad pro and outperforming the iphone 11
pro max
you see what i did there that that was
planned
yeah
cool huh
and before you ask it's perfectly
capable of running pubg at 90 hertz on
smooth
there said it done done stop no done
along with its amazing performance the
ipad air is also capable of giving its
users up to 10 hours of battery life
thanks to its 28.6 watt hour
rechargeable battery and of course those
who are planning to pick up the wi-fi
and cellular model you can expect up to
9 hours of battery life but that all
depends on your usage you can expect
about 2 hours and 47 minutes ish from a
zero to a full charge so that's pretty
much the basics let's take a minute to
see what apple has done to redesign the
ipad air to give users an even larger
display
of course they took out the home button
but the touch id sensor
now doubles as the sleep button giving
users a fast and secure way to unlock
their ipad and download apps and make
purchases through apple pay usb c for
charging is back and on top of that it
enables 5 gigabytes per second of data
transfer which is 10 times faster which
means that you can connect your external
4k monitors your external hard drives
and more in this iteration of the ipad
air which is a huge huge plus and with
the super fast wi-fi 6 capability
you can be well assured that you will
stay connected whether you're working
from home or anywhere actually as long
as it's wi-fi
right unfortunately the ipad air is not
5g enabled but
apple has made improvements on its lte
connectivity by making it 60 faster
we also see the second generation apple
pencil making its way to the ipad air
combined with ipad os 14 scribble offers
new ways to work with handwritten notes
its aim is to make handwriting as useful
as text on screen and so the ipad os 14
will make handwriting especially like
mine
it's totally awesome and convert it into
text it's also perfect for drawing note
taking marking up documents moreover no
more plugging in that apple pencil just
simply snap on
and snap off unlike the 8th generation
ipad come on guys apple pencil g1
seriously apple is of course known for
their cameras and the ipad air does not
disappoint there's a built-in 7
megapixel facetime hd camera and a 12
megapixel rear camera that's perfect for
taking amazing photos or video calling
your friends and family there is also 4k
video support up to 60 frames per second
and slo-mo video support for 1080p at
either 120 frames per second or 240
frames per second and in terms of
accessories apple's got you covered
aside from the smart keyboard folio ipad
owners can now choose to purchase this
glorious magic keyboard retailing for
439 singapore dollars for the 11 inch
model and 519 singapore dollars for the
12.9 inch model
with a new floating design that makes it
seem that your ipad is floating mid-air
it features a magnetic base for your
tablet to be placed on and uses the same
scissor mechanism as the keyboard on the
16-inch macbook pro
quality man quality prices for the
fourth generation ipad air starts from
879 singapore dollars for the wi-fi
model and
1079 singapore dollars for the wi-fi and
cellular model they are available in
five exciting colors
silver space gray rose gold green and
sky blue and are available in either 64
gigabytes or 256 gigabytes
configurations for those who have not
gotten one the second generation apple
pencil will be made available for
purchase separately at 138 singapore
dollars
of course smart covers are available for
the ipad air retailing at 75 singapore
dollars for those who want something
more
personalized in style there are seasonal
colors available such as deep navy
cypress green and pink citrus
so
that's it folks we are looking for a
professional tablet that's not only
sleek and lightweight but even has the
capability of powering through heavy
workloads and
even competitive gaming while still
maintaining a pretty decent price
you can expect the ipad pro lite i i
mean the ipad air
to be a pretty damn good deal and if you
like what you see don't forget to give
us a thumbs up do comment down below
which is your favorite ipad or what's
your favorite part of the ipad air and
if you haven't already don't forget to
subscribe and smash that notification
bell icon so you can stay updated to our
latest unboxings reviews and geeky
tidbits
until then this is zaki
signing off
[Music]
you